choice for my call today
-- the rules committee for
Thursday may sixteenth two by
called order appreciate vice
and audio and video recording
interface for see this buffet
is also mental powers of men
surgery please call the roll
Cooley here Cunningham Carillo
here flora Grayson Kamlager-Dove
here Maienschein Mathis
quirk Silva problems here Rivas
Wicks share we have we have a
quorum we have a consent agenda
some we haven't moved and
seconded that on the
as chair like to of yeah
on the side of his ten year his
request for the two seventeen
this bill would create taxes and
acted California as much time as
the land that
the requested on windows
server the homicide okay
-- we will remove item ten
addresses separately so we have
a motion on the main the consent
agenda moved and seconded by
right miss work second line
thank you very much -- answer
to please call the roll Cooley
hi Cooley aye Cunningham
Carillo Carillo aye flora
Grayson reason I Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis aye
Mathis aye aye quirk Silva Ramos
Ramos I Rivas realize I
works five weeks I'd much
process since past so then
we have is our motion on
item ten UC request
some of the screen second
by Mister Ramos -- question
racer Sir Mister chair
-- but just to clarify that the
vote we're about to take on item
ten is only to added urgency
clause and is not actually
voting on the bill itself
correct we don't have the we
strive to procedural matter and
enters urgency clause not on
the services the bill that
is correct thank you for good
-- sure span --
I miss grow certain of Armstrong
most masterpiece called Cooley
hi Cooley aye Cunningham Carillo
Carillo I've flora Grayson
Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I am Maienschein
in trying no Mathis Mathis
no quirk Silva Ramos Ramos
I Rivas hi three of us I Wicks
Wicks I -- that
motions passed and this rules
committee thank you very much